In this lesson,
you learned about key metrics and
how to go about measuring them.
Ultimately, your product and business
goals will form what you measure.
And don't forget that you can use the
heart framework to help you refine your
thinking and figure out next steps.
>> You heard from Aaron Harris
about vanity metrics and
about actionable metrics.
You also learned from other
startups about what they measure.
You have a great foundation for using
these metrics to improve your product.
Now it's time for
you to go out and do that.
>> We hope you enjoyed this course and
are eager to learn more
than what we covered here.
Continue to dream up amazing ideas, and
always push yourself to bring delightful
and useful products to the world.